starting for the padres vince velasquez
29 year old velasquez set to make his
first career start here at petco park
seventh career against the san francisco
giants overall this season
18 starts opponents hitting 245 big key
got to keep the ball in the ball yard 19
home runs in 85 plus innings he is ready
to go the bases are loaded with nobody
out
way two for three lifetime against
velazquez
and he eventually got him with a high
fastball
puts a little more pressure on the bat
for chris bryant sure does bryan two for
five lifetime against velazquez
blind
right center field nobody's there
it's gonna score two for sure
and here comes the third run and as john
miller would say
they all score
and it's three-nothing
take a look at the location two-seam
fastball that is a gift right out there
out of the on the outer half at the belt
and to bryant's credit he goes with the
location to the opposite gap
let the pitcher supply the power hit him
away right through the defense and
that's how you take advantage of the
bases loaded opportunity the first
kasmir the pitcher for the giants
tonight this is what he did in
sacramento this month he was one-on-one
with the 394 era with 17 strikeouts and
fernando chates jr leads off against him
swing ain't gonna miss he got him on
three pitches
and now machado who was
a night he had last night
on the ground a third for longoria
nice inning for kasmir it's called a
shut down inning
on weathers with the bases loaded two
down here in the second
on the ground to crawford
and that'll end the inning padres leave
him loaded machado bounced out to third
one pitch
driven to right field pretty deep wade
going back turns around that ball is off
the wall
machado's got a hold to his single
came off quickly and wade jr gets it
back in fast machado with a wall ball
single to right
i've said it before but i'll say it
again manny machado he squares up some
baseballs with consistent
consistency i should say and this is no
exception high two seamer now this
ball's hit so hard you know wade junior
plays as karim
his arm watch this throw
that's a strong throw yo
holding manny to a single
just got back yeah
got him
and he threw a perfect pitch and buster
posey hangs on
third strikeout one out
with will myers coming up
roll the crawford's gonna spin and throw
got him
he does it again
well you start talking about the degree
of difficulty on a play and for him to
have to go as hard as he was going to
his left
catch the ball
360
make an exchange and throw a strike now
remember i think it's a blind throw mike
or close and will myers has no backswing
and he can run so he gets out of the
right side of the batter's box
in a very quick fashion it's just a
spectacular play not even close you talk
about firing up a pitcher scott casper
that's a sincere wow
here's tommy lestella
lined and one hopper kind of explodes on
fernando still gets him
stayed with it kept it in front of him
and is able to throw out lu stella for
out number two
great second effort no panic
and you know what susan's balls up in
the air and he catches it clean he
realizes
i think at first he says i gotta really
get rid of this one but watch him as he
gets it and then kind of just passes it
over there's still stella hustling down
the line there
two-handed grab and then the flip throw
308 in this spot in his career one grand
slam on his resume
[Applause]
base is filled with friars
[Applause]
fouls it off beyond carrotini standing
in foul ground down there at third
catcher's interference looks that way
chronoworth headed to first base posey's
got his head down
from third comes carratini interference
from buster posey
the ultimate challenge for a relief for
coming into a bases loaded no out
situation
oh and by the way you're gonna face the
three four five guys one of which is
a red hot manny machado and doval throws
sliders struck it out swinging man he
broke off three of the best sliders that
you could possibly throw and he got him
to swing and miss at all three of them
here's tommy fan
on the ground could be a pair that's one
and what about duvall wow
the damage is one run
giants hang it on they lead three to one
first and third one out for crawford
crawford on the ground the other way a
base hit
that's gonna knock in buster posey it's
four to one
but just very
calmly goes with the
the location away so it'll be up to mike
yostremski to see if they can add on
a shot up to middle and a base hit
wade is going to score the giants up
their lead it's five to one
and he got a change up and he hammered
it up the middle
here's buster who's three for three
posey's got his fourth hit as he drives
it down the right field line
it's gonna knock in la stella the giants
lead six to one buster slides into
second with a double
and that's his second double of the game
seventh inning does this count as late
night for lamont wade
the 1-0 pitch
he pulls this one into right field off
the dive of cronenworth of course it's
late night le mans belt comes in to
score right behind a posey he'll score
eight to one giants lavon wade jr
two more runs batted in in the late
innings the giants have opened this game
up
[Applause]
one out and here's fernando
fly ball deep left field back goes
bryant at the wall there's 40.
fernando tatis jr gets his 40th home run
of the year
well we all know that it's been rough
sledding lately for san diego but i'll
tell you what congratulations to the kid
fernando tatis junior number 40.
so runner on second one out manny
machado at the plate
and as the base hit into left field
conorworth being waved around he will
score the third padres run as manny
machado drives it in
he's now 8-3
giants
here's eric hosmer now
[Applause]
reaches out up the middle by the dive to
crawford from third comes machado
and the potter is able to cut this lead
in half now it is eight to four
[Applause]
fam at third hosmer at second
on the ground right side la stella will
go to first for the out runnel score on
the back door comes fam
and it's now eight to five
comes trent grisham
liner to left and that's a base hit from
third comes hosmer to make it eight to
six
so two runs are in and the possible
winning run comes to the plate and the
padres will bring fernando tatis junior
to the plate
high and deep to left bryant is
underneath it and he makes the catch and
that's the ball game for a second i
thought it was gone
so did every giants fan in the world
[Applause]